alright darlin
Marla where'd you grow up were you from
I'm born and raised in Dallas Texas and
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents growing up yeah I had
a great childhood I was raised on a
thoroughbred ranch and I had no brothers
and sisters so I had a really great
childhood
Wow what do you free when you finally
left home when I was 18 two weeks after
my 18th birthday
my best friend and I pretty much threw
some darts at a map and decided to come
to Hollywood hmm how's that going which
country could spin us free of it I've
traveled cross-country and my favorite
is Hawaii and I didn't get him bald with
drugs till I was like in my late
thirties so it's kind of like a late
bloomer on that mmm I find myself now
and just kid ro strung out on just about
everything and desperate to get into
rehab and I don't it's been quite a
challenge getting in one so what drugs
are you using curly long heroin crack
cocaine weed and alcohol so you don't
use crystal meth no I can't stand
crystal mad mm-hmm and dude yep children
of y'all yeah I have two girls I was
sober for 12 beers in there I took a
break and got married and had two
children and that was so you were using
before that happened mmm and then you
got clean right how'd you get clean from
something I went to Tarzana treatment
center I stayed clean almost 11 years
mm-hmm what got you to relapse no I went
through a nasty divorce we just wanted
to set out for a while I know I had no
idea it wasn't leaving me down the skid
road though this is pretty traumatic
Jonny
that's pretty horrible yeah very
horrible down here so you're living in a
tent yeah I live in a tent on the
sidewalk right now I've been doing
everything I can to get my housing but
it just goes really slow it's really
scary down here for me cuz I'm by myself
and I'm white for one so like they don't
treat me very nice down here don't treat
any white people very nice down here
yeah you're a minority what what are you
doing for money now um I work on the
streets right I prosecute and I go in
stores and and steal things and bring
them back and get 50 cents on the dollar
for them have you had arrests for any of
this stuff yeah I've got arrested for
prostitution
mmm yeah it's just been one big
nightmare at this time it's not fun like
it used to be it was fun at one point
yeah at one point it was a lot of fun to
run the streets and run amok but it's
not anymore it's more like survival now
and guys have picked you up now are
pretty crazy should all of them can be
really mean how do you have you had
instances where they were violent or oh
sure yeah I've had them pull downs or
knives out on man yeah I've had some
pretty rough things happen yeah you've
had I can't hardly sleep anymore cuz I
have issues with sleeping and waking up
and having people in my tent and doing
horrible things to me so it's hard for
me to sleep down yeah I heard that a lot
or woman will wake up with a guy in
their tent
yeah a total stranger yeah it's pretty
scary they do it a lot around here
I mean how many years eve Mindy that's
good well I've been down here for six
years now six years how do you think
that's changed you six years here oh wow
definitely made my my skin a little
tougher I would have to say in mmm just
in just everyday dealing with people is
everything down here is switched around
it's so backwards when I get on the
train and go to go to Long Beach or
Hollywood or something I have to like
reprogram myself because you know the
way we live down here and the way people
treat you and the way you treat people
is totally different down here then you
know in the real world
yeah pretty backwards down here do you
sell them contact with your your kids or
your family mmm my husband my husband
won't let me see your talk to them on
getting loaded my mom is all I have left
and they're all pretty disappointing
with me right now so I'm really turning
it into rehab too
I just don't see myself lasting you down
here too much longer if I don't what do
you need nor to get rehab to work to be
clean I mean oh I need to uh I need some
insurance some medical insurance which I
just got and um yeah like an ID and a
social every time I get an ID and a
social and stuff my purse gets stolen
them it's really rough down here keeping
like credentials and a cellphone things
that you really need every day life that
you need it's really difficult to keep a
hold of those things down here yeah
everything gets stolen like almost daily
yeah yeah I've had a hundred phones I
blink and they get stolen yeah so it's
really hard to keep hold of like family
and friends keep in touch with room
crews I can't keep a cellphone and yeah
this is really hard and if you if you
don't do this the alternative is you end
up living the rest of your life down
here yeah a lot of my friends have died
down here I don't want to leave in a
pine box
ya know I'm doing so a drugs you're
doing pretty dangerous
yeah really dangerous
you just get to a point where you don't
care sometimes and because you're so
isolated from everybody who cares about
you you start believing that nobody
cares anymore it's just it's a bunch of
[ __ ] your head PC you start to
believe it and getting clean from heroin
I've heard it's really high
yeah thirty seconds like dying yeah and
I would I I really want to do it
nowadays it's rough you know because the
insurance and medical and and the type
of drugs I'm on it's like a really high
risk just get me clean off of those
things without you know me going into
seizures or dying or something so it's
really challenging trying to get into a
medical facility cuz none of them on it
help you
there's just such a high risk Gary
Barlow well thank you so much for coming
in and tell me your story and good luck
with the getting into rehab and all the
stuff I'm determined all right thank you
cool I'm so glad you told me to come in
to ask me if you come in
you